si on devait faire le portrait robot de
la famille des al nabawi franchement ils
se rapprocheraient fortement d'ayem ah
bah ça c'est le portrait craché veille
non j'adore le charme oriental comme ça
les débits noir les yeux bouche pulpeuse
l'effort j'adore la trouve superbe façon
cryptée
[Rires]
jean-michel si vous étiez célibataire je
le suis jean michel est ce que vous
auriez pu être intéressé par à y eu m a
complètement mais je le suis abonnée aux
gens c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que
vous êtes aussi beaugas aujourd'hui
contient moi je pense
voilà c'est vrai alors en fait c'est
donc parce que vous vous avez fait en
fait l'accord est rejeté sur isabelle
vous avez vu que c'était pas possible
mais c'est vrai après j'ai appris
méfie toi est-ce que réciproquement peu
de monde et ayem si par hasard va lui
demander tout à l'heure à l'emploi trop
vite en besogne cayenne allons je reste
pour l'instant à tabac je rappelle qu
ayem est en intérieur cuir noir
donc on verra ça tout à l'heure bien
entendu